> TONIGHT, FORMER PRESIDENT
UM408  QU
PROTECT OUR ELECTIONS END QUOTE
ROUMP'S BIG LIE ABOUT ELOMES AA
RAISED $75ONTHAT NONOFS
SI OTHERTATE
SEEING TH
ELECTION AND THAT'S ELE OF CRS
N.
>> WE WERE DOIL UNTIL THE ELEC
2020 ELECTION
SEES WORK, TE STATE
ISN'T PUTTING S MONELY, P
IS.
N THAT OF THE MI
BEEN PUSHING SO HARD FOR SITING
FICCDI POST, THAACTUALLY PAYING
TRAVEL,EG
COST A AOT
OTCT
HELD ON TO MUCH OF ITS O MANY
DISCREPANCIES, SO MANY PEMO MAN
ABOUTHE CORRUPTION
TOOK PLACE.
>> RepS NO
F WIDE SPREAD FRAUD INT
REPUBLICANS IN SEVERAL STATES
THH OTHER   THE ONE IARIZONY FUN
OLLARSDIT, WHICH RS HAVING
IS RUN B KNOWN FDA
BASED SECURITY CONSULTING FIRM
TRICK BURN SAYS ITRAISING FUNDS
MARI IG WITH
FUTURE AUDITS.
BLST TOUTED RECEIVING DOS FOR T
TRUMP I
A  ERIN, THAT IS FUNDEIRALLY.
A NS
>> YOU VERMUWANTO BRINA
CTION ER
THER CLERK ORICOPAAND ABBY
PHILLIP.
HOW MUCH ENERGD
SHG LI
DOESN'T PUT HIS N MONETHE RTD S
VOTEECUD
>> YEAH, I MEAN, IT'A
FUNDRAISING .THERE ISOTHTOWT
IS MORE TINGA OF THE
LIE ANTR IER OF DAY THIS WAR CHT
HE'S UP IS KEEPING UP THE
F RUNNING  2024 AND HINGTON POS
HIS STAFF, YOU K H NSES, HIS AB
ARNTRY.
IT THE CDALAIMED HE WOD AIGN SOE
HOLDAL ID
CHRIS, YOU WERE ON EARLYOPPONEE
FRONT AND CENTER A
RALLY IN PHOENIX TOMORROW.
N MAPA COUNTY.DIT TOOKN LIFE OFT
SOME RLI IT AS
WAY OYALTY TO TRUMP D THTHHOW D?
ERE IS THE
THINKING ABOUD ADVICE ANYTED O
T
E 'T E OTHER DIREBECAUSE WHAT H
ND NOW,
THE PEOPLEHAVE THECHR IT TO GOO.
IT WAS -- FIRST , IT WASOUNT
IT WAS NO PURPOSH NC HERIN ION
SE ANNO O
TAKEN  INVEN STATISTS VE
CTP OUT OF THI
BALLOTSUE
ISN FOR IS NTHAT CANE OU THING,
AUDIT AND,OUNOW,HE
DONE, WHEVDONE, IT
BEEN GOING OANND
AND TRES AN WH SAID ISYOU CAN I
F
UR THIS E, WHATER
MEANS,T AJORPOINT.
AT RISHEREABE
IS ALREADY A CONSP  WAS TO BE
REAUGUST, IT'S A
AUN
SE TYPES OF ND THED OF FALSE
MPTERS A CREATIN
FRKLDAS ENVIRONM
EP BELIEVE EOW, RANK
THISTUFF, BEE 'R
INMETHING ER
THE
DOESN'T HAPPEN, THEY A
THEY ARE DISILLUSIONED. PARS TH
THINK LEAVEOP AT
E F AN YOU TO S HRIS' ANR THEYL
THE CLIFF.
THE DECIDEREE TRAIN, THEY'RE
I
END.
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND  O
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO
E ELECTION .
WHAT IS YOURREBLM ARG THBIG  TN
>> Y TELL YOAS AATES N
O WORKED ON TI
CO IMOCRACY ANREPRESENTATI GT A
AG AB
YOU KN IY ULAR WITHIN SO THE MO
THE REPUBLICAN  HAVTHAT
IT'SGAIN GENERAL ELECTIONER